and y'all can see me coming like a
comment here
and all i do is
v welcome to pacifica
pretty quick on the dial just got here
that's the biz be in touch
[Music]
thanks eyes peeled
was it worth it on a scale from one to
six
i'd say i'm sitting at a strong six
i guess we both know what's going to
happen next
misses you i'm here to shut you down
really appreciate it if you didn't make
this difficult
i have a surprise waiting for you after
this
[Music]
so i'll just give you a hint
i'm going to kill you and all the cake
is gone
i honestly truly didn't think you'd fall
for that
okay that's enough you chose this path
now i have a surprise for you deploying
surprise in five
four let's see
turning soft
[Music]
what you bodies
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
you're scared
i hate you so much
[Music]
here come the test results you are a
horrible person
i'm serious that's what it says
a horrible person we weren't even
testing for that
going back to delhi really so scary you
gotta drag this out
i let you survive this long because i
was curious about your behavior
well you've managed to destroy that part
of me
a bitter unlikable learner whose passing
shall not demand
enough what's your point anyway
survival you're still shuffling around a
little
but believe me you're dead
how do you the talking is over
i'm going back
i've made contact with the missing
vehicle
definitely the artist of the bunch
yes particularly impertinent that one
a share of your fee is being processed
i